quand je suis en pleine forme je suis un
peu bronzouillée et puis que je sors
comme une jolie robe je faisais frais
quelque chose de nouveau et puis que je
suis sifflé dans la rue mais pas si fait
en tant que Mario Pacôme ah bon monsieur
comme ça
et bien ça fait chaud au cœur c'est
formidable et là je m'aperçois je dis la
petite alerte tu tiens Maria tuillais
car quand j'étais sifflé quand j'avais
20 ou 1 ça m'exaspéré alors que
maintenant ça me fait plaisir parce que
c'est rassurant puis il y a la chirurgie
esthétique c'est pour ça ah moi j'y
pense moi je suis pour parce que je me
dis si là ça va bien mon Dieu je
m'écroule un petit peu dans un petit
lifting c'est pas ça fait une mal à
personne on voit on montre un visage un
peu plus frais et puis c'est beaucoup
mieux aussi bien pour moi je dis pas
pour les autres et tu es en train de
dire ou pour les autres pour ses enfants
mais non c'est pour moi quand je regarde
ma bouille dans la glace je veux pas
voir alors ça m'embêterait de mes je
crois pas que je m'écroulerais
voyez-vous j'aurais
pas je serais pas une vieille pomme je
pense pas